il y a comme un air de déjà vu le
casse-tête de l'enseignement distanti
elle est de retour et un an après
enseignants et élèves font à nouveau
face aux mêmes problématiques fracture
numérique ma logements par an dans
l'incapacité de surveiller la scolarité
de leurs enfants car ils travaillent
un an après le premier confinement et
l'histoire semble se répéter
notamment pour les élèves des milieux
ruraux ou défavorisés on retrouve
toujours les mêmes difficultés chez les
familles que l'an passé
le manque de matériel informatique
surtout chez les fratries les connexions
internet défaillante
les collectivités ont beau communiquer
sur les distributions qu'elles ont
effectué tous les problèmes sont loin
d'être réglés
il faut aussi étudier ce qui va être
proposé aux élèves en termes
pédagogiques
prise de court par les annonces du
président de la république les équipes
pédagogiques ont dû s'activer pour être
prête dès le mardi 6 avril afin de
préserver la fameuse continuité
pédagogique
ce nouveau confinement n'a pas été mieux
anticiper on se retrouve dans la même
situation d'urgence qu'il ya un an
c'est épuisant ce déni de réalité mais
du côté du ministère de l'éducation
nationale le ton se veut rassurant
quitte à ignorer les alertes jean michel
blanquer air avait même affirmé fin août
dernier nous sommes préparés à tout mais
la réalité du terrain le contredit
encore une fois aujourd'hui
le ministre avait assuré que
l'institution scolaire avait les
ressources en ligne permettant d'assurer
une continuité pédagogique de qualité
alors que les professeurs se débrouille
avec les moyens du bord et tente de
développer des techniques d'enseignement
hybride
l'éducation nationale n'a toujours pas
mis en place des formations
d'enseignement à distance
aucun prof n'a eu de vraies formations
sur l'enseignement à distance qui pose
encore de nombreuses difficultés
on l'a encore vu récemment lorsque des
classes ont été fermées pour des cas de
co vite 19 un enseignement à distance
qui pourraient être améliorées à l'aide
d'outils régulé par le ministère la
france a été l'un des derniers pays à
avoir fermé ses écoles face à la
troisième vague épidémique
alors que ces dernières semaines et les
syndicats d'enseignants clamer haut et
fort que le protocole sanitaire était
insuffisant jean michel blanquer a campé
sur ses positions
les écoles ne devait pas fermée pendant
ce temps des milliers de
la sphère mais face à la recrudescence
de 99
encore une fois les chiffres
contredisent les slogans édulcorée de
l'éducation nationale selon santé
publique france on dénombré 34 mille
trois cents élèves du primaire et du
secondaire positif pour la seule journée
du 22 mars mais le ministère se défend
il a mis en place quelques ressources en
ligne avec une série de fiches publié
sur son site eduscol leclerc de centre
national d'enseignement à distance
propose de son côté un dispositif
complet et gratuit
mais si l'éducation nationale a bien
fourni quelques outils la réalité du
terrain reste la même un an après le
premier confinement pour les élèves et
les enseignants qui craignent un
décrochage scolaire